is tonight's la screening the first well
the the screening at the 8th annual La
Femme international film festival is
considered a world premiere and it's
booked at that as we had a sneak preview
in Chicago where we're testing the
message and seeing how people reacted
and it was it was it was great there I
had people from all walks of life see
the film in Chicago even a Chicago
20-year Police Force veteran said boy if
I could show this film to everybody I
wouldn't have a job and I would love
that but tonight is really the the big
night that we have in Los Angeles and
then that is followed a week from today
by the the premiere theatrical run at
harkins theatres and so to last week as
of a week ago two weeks before that
theatrical opening we sold out the 450
seats in the first official theatrical
run so it's a filmmakers dream when you
come out is that the people want to see
it and the other shows are booking up to
so and how did you spread word about the
screenings it's like everything else in
this film it started as grass roots word
of mouth and you do as a filmmaker what
you have to do I contacted everyone in
my email list my doctors my holistic
health care my little lawyers everybody
I ever knew that I personally contacted
and got a wonderful response but then
all the people that have been part of
the project have been getting the word
out and and sharing then my speakers
have been sending emails to their list
and Facebook and social media so it
really is like the film it's a
collective effort of everybody
contributing any other you know
memorable experiences from people after
seeing the screen coming up to
talking to you how it affected them well
it's personally really meaningful to me
when women come up in tears and say
thank you so much for sharing your
message I feel like I have hope now
because they haven't had tools they've
gone to head based therapy and talked
about it but when you can see the
process that I show what worked for me
they say wow I'm excited again I think
that I can take this on and heal and do
it quickly as we talk about that in the
film and we also have then interesting
i've had interesting commentary from
people were you know just a little part
of the film that didn't seem to have a
whole lot of impact for me people would
come up and say all that part of the
movie where that one former lawyer says
I needed to decide what my day was going
to be like and am I happy that really
spoke to me so I have a lot of different
you know feedback that you know
everybody gets something out of the film
that helps them
you